-Republicans have done
so little,
and what they have done
is so unpopular
that their only strategy
for the midterms
is to make up a racist scam
to scare people.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The one constant
in Donald Trump's life
from his earliest days
in Manhattan real estate to now
is that he is a scam artist.
He literally sold scam products
from a vitamin kit that was
determined by a urine test
to a Trump deodorant.
And I have to say
the last person
I would buy deodorant from
is Donald Trump.
I mean, look at
how sweaty he gets.
Can you imagine the ad
for that deodorant?
"Trump deodorant.
Always let 'em see you sweat."
In fact, just this week,
a new lawsuit
was filed
in Manhattan Federal Court
accusing the Trump family
of defrauding investors
by selling them
get-rich-quick schemes.
-President Trump,
three of his adult children,
and their company
are now facing a new lawsuit
over allegedly conning consumers
in a "systematic fraud
and pattern of racketeering."
-The federal lawsuit was filed
today in Manhattan,
and it accuses Trump,
his company,
and three of his children
of promoting
get-rich-quick schemes
that have harmed investors,
and that includes
a telecommunications
marketing firm,
the Trump Network,
which marketed vitamins,
and the Trump Institute,
which offered
real-estate seminars.
-I can't believe
Trump had an institute.
I just assumed he escaped
FROM an institute.
Trump's been selling scams
his whole life.
If he weren't president,
he'd be selling
counterfeit video games
out of the back of his Camaro.
"It's an Xbok.
It's just as good."
[ Laughter ]
And like the grifter he is,
Trump just makes stuff up
off the top of his head
to lure in gullible people.
In a Fox interview this week,
for example,
he claimed he saved us
from a war with North Korea
that would have
definitely happened
if President Obama
were still in office.
-You have news out there
that is so fake.
And I can do the
greatest thing ever.
North Korea as an example.
We would have been going to war
with North Korea.
I think President Obama
would have gone to war very --
If he had an extra year,
he would be in right now
a war with North Korea.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, uh, I'm sorry.
I was just dreaming about
an extra year of Obama.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I asked a team of
computer scientists to estimate
how much younger
I'd look right now
if Obama had been president
for an extra year,
and this is what
they came up with.
[ Laughter ]
And now as President Trump
is just selling his supporters
more scam products,
he's replaced the vitamin kit
and the deodorant
with a Space Force
and a border wall,
things he'll never
actually deliver.
Just take the wall.
It doesn't exist.
It's never going to exist.
So now Trump is sending troops
to the border in a stunt
and claiming that's
just as good as a wall.
-You're talking about 10,000,
maybe 15,000
active-duty U.S. military
to the border --
more than we have fighting
the Taliban in Afghanistan,
more than we have
fighting ISIS in Syria.
You're really gonna do that?
>> It's very important. We have
to have a wall of people.
-That's right -- the wall
isn't made of bricks anymore.
It's made of people.
"Our amazing troops
are going to the border
where we will stack them on top
of each other Tetris-style."
[ Laughter ]
Republicans...
[ Applause ]
Republicans make stuff up
because they can't defend
their actual record.
For example, the GOP
passed a healthcare bill
in the House last year
that would have stripped away
protections
for preexisting conditions,
and it was massively unpopular.
So now that they're
running for re-election,
they're just lying about it.
-We can protect
preexisting conditions.
And you need to understand
everyone agrees we're gonna
protect preexisting conditions.
-I am passionate about
protecting people with
preexisting conditions.
-We will always
protect Americans
with preexisting conditions.
-Republicans will protect people
with preexisting conditions
far better than the Dems.
-The president's healthcare plan
that he's laid out
covers preexisting conditions.
-Okay, first, his plan doesn't
cover preexisting conditions.
Second, he doesn't have a plan.
The House passed a bill
last year.
That plan failed in the Senate.
And then we never
heard about it again.
Sarah Sanders managed to
cram two lies into one sentence.
She's like the
Rick Steves of lying.
"I'll show you
how to pack two lies,
a misdirection,
and three evasive answers
into a simple carry-on."
Republicans don't want people
thinking about
their healthcare bill
or the massive tax cut
they gave to the wealthy,
so that's why they're
frantically spouting
one racist [bleep] idea
after another.
Like Trump's latest stunt
over birthright citizenship,
a right enshrined
in the 14th Amendment.
Automatic citizenship
for anyone born in this country
is the pillar of our
post Civil War attempt
to build an inclusive democracy.
And yet Trump claimed this week
that he could just
unilaterally change it
through an executive order,
something he obviously
cannot do.
>> It was always told to me
that you needed
a Constitutional amendment.
Guess what. You don't.
-You don't.
-Number one,
you don't need that.
Number two --
-That's very much in dispute.
-Well, you can definitely do it
with an act of Congress.
But now they're saying
I can do it just with
an executive order.
-Have you talked about that
with counsel?
-Yeah. I have.
-So, where in the process --
-It's in the process.
It'll happen.
With an executive order. That's
what you're talking about.
I didn't think
anybody knew that but me.
I thought I was the only one.
-Yeah, you thought you were
the only one because it's crazy.
Trump's like a guy who gets
put in an insane asylum,
and when his roommate says,
"You know, the Statue of Liberty
has been spying on me,"
Trump goes, "You too?
I thought I was the only one."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And now Republicans,
who spent years paying
lip service to the Constitution,
have been twisting
themselves in knots
to align themselves
with Trump --
like Texas senator Ted Cruz,
who's fully embraced Trump
in his tight re-election bid.
When Cruz, a Constitutional
lawyer, was asked about
Trump's comments,
he said, "I have long supported
ending birthright citizenship.
I would need to examine
the legal arguments
behind an executive order,
and I haven't seen those yet."
So, there you go.
Ted Cruz says he needs to
look at the legal arguments.
If only he had known this guy
running for Senate back in 2011.
-The 14th Amendment provides
for birthright citizenship.
I've looked at the legal
arguments against it,
and I will tell you,
as a Supreme Court litigator,
those arguments
are not very good.
As much as someone may dislike
the policy of
birthright citizenship,
it's in the U.S. Constitution.
-Wow.
Somehow, Cruz lying
is only the second-grossest
thing about that clip
after his hair.
I mean, look how sweaty he is.
Is he using Trump deodorant?
All of this birthright
citizenship talk
is an extension
of Trump's latest attempt
to scare people
about a migrant caravan
heading toward
our southern border.
In reality, the caravan is a few
thousand vulnerable people
fleeing poverty and violence,
who are still thousands of miles
and months away
if they even get here at all.
But if you listen to Trump,
it's an imminent invasion
full of criminals
and terrorists.
-At this very moment,
large, well-organized caravans
of migrants are marching toward
our southern border.
Some people call it an invasion.
It's like an invasion.
You're gonna find MS-13,
you're gonna find
Middle Eastern.
You're gonna find everything.
-These are some bad people
coming through.
These aren't babies.
These aren't little angels
coming into our country.
It's actually mostly young men
and a lot of rough people.
There's a lot of rough people,
John.
They're pushing the women
right up into the front --
not good --
and they're pushing the few kids
right up to the front.
When you look at that caravan,
and you look --
largely, very, you know,
big percentage of men,
young, strong.
-He sounds like
a Long Island divorcée
trying to convince her friends
to go out to a club.
"There will be lots of men,
young, strong.
They love to travel."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, implying that
they're young, strong men
is just another
racist dog whistle
designed to scare people,
and in doing that,
Trump has had the help of a
right-wing propaganda outlet
that exists entirely
for one purpose --
to disseminate his lies
and whip its audience
into a racist frenzy,
and over the last few days,
Fox News
has gone into overdrive,
telling people
there might be more caravans
and that those caravans
might be spreading disease.
-This is an invasion.
This is an act of attacking
the United States' sovereignty.
-This is a threatening,
invading force
that may well
bash its way through our fence
the way they did
the Guatemalan fence.
-What about diseases?
I mean, there's a reason why
you can't bring a kid to school
unless he's inoculated.
-They're coming in with diseases
such as smallpox and leprosy
and TB that are gonna infect our
people in the United States.
-Smallpox and leprosy?
Where is this caravan
coming from, medieval England?
[ Laughter and applause ]
The last --
True story.
The last naturally occurring
case of smallpox was in 1977.
It really makes your
scare-mongering
a lot less convincing when the
only diseases you can think of
are from the "Oregon Trail."
But the weirdest example of Fox
spreading this racist hoax
was a segment on
Lou Dobbs' show on Monday.
Dobbs might be Fox's most
virulent conspiracy theorist.
After mail bombs were sent
to prominent Democrats,
he called them fake.
He's also been
obsessively tracking
the location of the caravan,
which,
as we showed you last week,
has sometimes given him
pronunciation trouble.
-The caravan of mostly
Central American immigrants
is now in the Mexican city
of Wah-la-da tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-Now I just wanted
to show you that
to give you some context
for this next clip.
Dobbs had a guest on
who floated a theory
about the migrants spreading
disease that was so crazy,
even Dobbs
couldn't go along with it.
-We simply cannot tolerate
the continued invasion
of this country when Americans
are suffering every day.
The national debt is exploding.
We have diseases spreading
across the country
that are causing polio-like
paralysis of our children.
It's one thing after the other.
-You can't very well blame that
disease on illegal immigrants.
We don't know the cause of it.
I don't know that that's --
I don't think that's fair.
A lot of, you know --
But there are plenty of reasons
to keep this country secure,
including -- including --
making sure that everyone
is healthy when they are
brought into the country,
without question, right?
Is that fair?
-That is fair.
But that is part of the problem.
We don't know where the diseases
are coming from.
-[ Laughing ] Well, that's --
You know what?
I think, with that,
we're going to leave it.
[ Laughter ]
-"Wah-da-la!"
Lou Dobbs just had that moment
that a lot of us had in our 20s.
Remember, you're at a party
at someone's house,
and you look around, and you go,
"Man, everybody at this party
is an ass [bleep]."
And then you go,
"Wait. I'm at this party."
[ Laughter ]
The caravan hysteria
has spun so far out of control
that Shepherd Smith
actually had to look
straight into the camera
this week
and reassure Fox viewers
that they were not in danger.
-The migrants, according to
Fox News reporting,
are more than two months away.
If any of them
actually come here.
But tomorrow is one week
before the midterm election,
which is what
all of this is about.
There is no invasion.
No one's coming to get you.
There's nothing at all
to worry about.
-Oh, my God. Fox News
has gone so far off the rails
that the only sane person
who works there
has to talk to viewers
like children
who accidentally
saw a scary movie.
[ Laughter ]
"It's okay.
There's nothing to worry about.
The Babadook is not real..."
[ Laughter ]
"...and it is not
coming to get you."
And that's great.
The only problem is,
a few hours later,
Sean Hannity comes on
the same network
and screams,
"The Babadook is real,
and it's outside your house!"
[ Laughter ]
The caravan hysteria is a con
designed to distract everyone
while Trump and his cronies
plunder the government
for their own personal gain.
That's a point Obama
made over the weekend
when he was campaigning
in Wisconsin.
-They're trying to convince
everybody to be afraid
of bunch of impoverished,
malnourished refugees
a thousand miles away.
It's this group of folks,
we don't even
know where they are.
They're way down there.
[ Laughter ]
That's the biggest thing!
And you know as soon as
the election's over...
Everybody will be like,
"What? What happened?
We were be being invaded?
Where'd it go?"
They're giving tax cuts
out to billionaires.
They don't want you
to notice that.
"Look, look, look!
Over there!"
[ Laughter ]
They're sabotaging
your healthcare.
"No, wait!
Look, look!"
It's like a con,
where a door-to-door salesman
tries to sell you
a security system
while his buddy sneaks
in the back,
takes all your stuff.
It's like "Home Alone."
You remember that movie?
-Oh, my God.
He's right.
It is like "Home Alone."
And Trump was in that, too.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Trump's racist fear-mongering
over immigration
is the latest scam from a guy
who's been scamming people
his entire life.
And he's right at home
in the modern GOP.
They're robbing you,
and they're trying
to distracting you
while they do it.
They're hoping you won't notice
until it's too late,
and then you'll say...
-What?
W-What happened?
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]